[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
oprah i'm riding you because i'm in love
with taylor swift and i don't know if
i'm delusional or not letters to famous
celebrities take center stage as the man
accused of shooting up a tennessee
waffle house stands trial and at this
time the jury has reached
unanimous verdicts on both counts a
shocking verdict in ohio for the trial
of audrey cole did the jury believe her
self-defense claim plus the pike county
massacre when the wagner family could
finally stand trial but first the nfl is
slammed with a racial discrimination
lawsuit why texts from patriots head
coach bill belichick are cited in court
documents law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a racial discrimination lawsuit
takes the nfl by storm as co-host terry
austin explains texts that surfaced from
patriots head coach bill belichick has
the league and multiple teams in hot
water terry
brian the lawsuit stems from brian
flores a 40 year old former black nfl
coach who filed an employment class
action lawsuit against the nfl the miami
dolphins the denver broncos and the new
york giants last month flores was fired
as coach of the miami dolphins and has
been interviewing for a new coaching
position
glories claims that the giants
interviewed him under false pretenses he
says that he received a congratulatory
text from new england patriots coach
bill belichick which was intended for
brian dayball who is white
flores alleges that his interview with
the giants was a ruse so the team could
demonstrate compliance with the rooney
rule the nfl instituted the rooney rule
back in 2003 to increase increase
diversity in the nfl's executive ranks
the rule requires every team to
interview at least two external minority
candidates for open head coaching
positions
currently only one out of 27 head
coaches employed in the nfl is black in
a league where roughly 70 percent of the
players are black
long prime reached out to the patriots
who declined to comment representatives
with the giants tell us they are
confident with the hiring process we're
still waiting to hear back from flores
and on wednesday news also broke that
former cleveland browns coach hugh
jackson alleges the browns paid him to
lose games back in 2016 and 2017. brian
thanks terry joining us today is
criminal defense attorney adam konta and
terry austin as we review the play on
the field so to speak adam the belichick
text message that seems to be the
biggest thing at least i see um how
damaging is that evidence and how do you
think it's going to be used to argue
forza's case
well it's devastating i mean these text
messages it's bill belichick texting the
wrong guy that he got the job and this
was three days he was trying to text
dabel instead of brian flores but he
sent this text to brian flores three
days before his interview which
demonstrates the giants already had made
up their mind and decided to hire dabul
well before the interview meaning that
the interview was absolutely just a sham
to carry carry out the rooney rule if
you look at the hiring of black coaches
and since the running rule came into
existence it's only 15 out of 129
candidates back in 2008 there were like
eight black coaches right now there's
only one and the the lawsuit that they
filed really really details um a real
pattern of systemic racism that i think
these text messages are going to be the
linchpin and it's really going to go to
uh
i think an explosive and explosive
investigation i'm really excited to see
what comes of this yeah terry hugh
jackson just made a similar claim is
this a class action suit yet um what
does it need to become one and is it a
strong one if more people join
well i think it's a very strong case it
has like adam said some very damning
allegations but to be a class action you
have to have individuals who have
similar legal questions and and patterns
of fact so i think they'll be able to do
that here and the only question is will
they get people to join because they
might be afraid it'll ruin their career
yeah well we've got flores now we've got
jackson the question of who's going to
be the third fourth fifth and
potentially more in this civil sorry in
this class actions lawsuit thank you
both on update now on a story we first
brought you earlier this week a second
bridgeport connecticut family says
police did not notify them after the
death of their loved one brenda lee
rawls died on december 12th of last year
yes that's the exact same day as 23 year
old lauren smith fields both are black
women from bridgeport smithfield's
family has been a vocal about police
mishandling the investigation and claims
authorities did not contact them when
she died while smithfield's death was
ruled an accidental overdose critics say
the death investigation was botched two
officers involved in the case were put
on administrative leave and a third
retired in a statement bridgeport
connecticut's mayor says he demands
answers
i want to be clear to members of the
public and the department that
insensitivity disrespect and action or
deviation for policy will not be
tolerated by me
or anyone in this administration
my disappointment
in demand for accountability in these
and other matters brought to my
attention
will remain
in all until all the questions
that have been asked
are answered to the satisfaction
in new york closing arguments are
presented in the federal trial of
disgrace attorney michael avenatti on
tuesday prosecutors told jurors avenatti
quote unquote spun a web of lies to his
former client stormy daniels prosecutors
allege avenatti stole 300 000
from daniels by secretly pocketing part
of daniel's book advance but before that
avenatti rose to fame representing
daniels as the adult film actress who
had an affair with former president
donald trump daniels detailed that
relationship in her memoir titled full
disclosure avenatti who elected to
represent himself presented closing
arguments on wednesday after wrestling
the defense's case without calling a
single witness including not taking the
stand himself he spoke to jurors in the
third person saying things like quote
there is insufficient evidence to show
that michael avenatti ever intended to
hurt stormy daniels avenatti has pled
not guilty to the charges
still ahead on law and crime daily the
speedy trial of audrey cole where a
verdict is reached just two days after
jury selection
but first we head to ohio for the latest
on the pike county massacre angela levy
is live to explain what's next for the
wagner family
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a father and son charged in
one of ohio's largest murder cases
appear in court and a trial day has been
set for one of them long crimes angela
levy is here with the latest on the pike
county massacre and jeanette
brian george wagner the fourth trial is
now set to begin on august 29th jury
selection will start about five and a
half weeks before on july 5th in pike
county now that date was set at a brief
pre-trial hearing wagner his father
billy and mother and brother jake and
angela are charged with murdering eight
members of the rodent and gilly families
in april of 2016. that's nearly six
years ago jake and angela have already
pleaded guilty and have agreed to
testify against billy and george jake
wagner told prosecutors his family
carried out the murders so they could
have sole custody of a daughter he
shared with one of the victims hannah
rhoden
meanwhile attorneys for billy wagner and
prosecutors have agreed that his trial
should start sometime around october of
this year although an exact date has not
yet been set billy wagner appeared in
court this week he and george are both
trying to have ballistics and shoe
impression evidence against them
suppressed prosecutors have said a gun
jake wagner owned fired some of the
bullets used in the murders and that
that gun left a unique impression on the
shell casings prosecutors say jake
wagner led them to the murder weapons
after he confessed judge randy dearing
asked billy wagner a few questions
during his hearing
are you satisfied with
the your access to your attorneys the
frequently with the frequency with what
you're seeing and so forth yeah okay he
missed his christmas visit your honor
that's why
he missed his christmas visit but i'm
not i'd be satisfied are you satisfied
with the services they're providing in
your defense so far okay and do you have
any uh any objections to anything that's
going on any
not at this time
now back to george wagner's trial which
is now scheduled to begin in august it's
really possible that that trial could be
moved to another county but according to
ohio law they must try to seat a jury in
the county where the charges were filed
first if they're not able to find a fair
and impartial jury there then the trial
could be moved pike county of course has
a small jury pool the population is less
than 28 000 and prospective jurors are
pulled randomly from a list of
registered voters and
licensed drivers so that makes the pool
of potential
potential jurors even smaller brian
thanks angeannette let's bring back
criminal defense attorney adam conte and
terry austin to discuss the remaining
pike county massacre cases terry given
that the county is so small we heard
angina kind of go over it just a moment
ago and this is such a national case
what are the odds of getting this trial
moved to a different county and what
would that entail
the odds are slim to none brian in my
opinion i think that they'd have to
argue obviously that there's been
excessive pretrial publicity and that
the jury pool is biased and they need an
impartial jury obviously under the
constitution they have a right to that
but i think that no matter where you go
this case is so well known you're not
going to get a jury who doesn't know
about the case you just have to make
sure doing vardir that you get jurors
who promise to be fair and impartial
because that's all you can ask for
absolutely adam after yesterday's
hearing bill wagner looks to be on track
for a trial do you think that's wise
though with so many family members
likely to testify against him
i just don't believe it honestly i think
it's uh it's to buy more time and we're
talking about a trial date in october
we're in january you're talking about
something that's 10 months from now i
just don't believe that they genuinely
think that this case is going to trial
between now and then i think they think
it's a possibility but i think this is
more of a tactic to be able to figure
out if there's a plea that makes sense i
still think changing venues is a
possibility with a pool that small
but they're certainly going to look into
it more but i think when this plays out
over the next six seven months we'll
we'll see something different than it
heading to trial in october all right
we'll see how it plays out like as you
say and yet how do the rhodian and gilly
family members feel about these cases
going to trial in a potential plea deal
you know going through a trial is
difficult for any family member of a
murder victim but here you have eight
murder victims so
this is going to be difficult for these
family members to sit through although
they have wanted to see some sort of
justice for a long time almost six years
it'll be more than six years by the time
george wagner iv
goes to trial i know that during the or
after the plea hearing for jake wagner
uh the family members seem very happy
he's going to prison for the rest of his
life they didn't seem quite as happy
after angela wagner pleaded guilty
because she's eligible for release after
serving 30 years all right we'll see how
these pike county massacre cases
continue as adam said it's months and
months out maybe there's a plea maybe
it's a trout we'll see how that ends up
thank you all coming up on law and crime
daily day four of the waffle house
shooting trial hear first hand letters
the defendant wrote to pop icon taylor
swift plus a shocking verdict is reached
in the andre cole murder trial out of
ohio all that and more still ahead on
law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back an ohio veteran on trial
for murder is now a free woman after a
not guilty verdict from the jury audrey
cole was charged with murder and
felonious assault in the shooting death
of her boyfriend matthew mott last year
the two were both military veterans and
had domestic issues in the past in may
2021 the couple allegedly got into an
argument over their three-year-old
daughter taking medication cole said
mott beat her and threw her head into a
wall before she shot and killed him with
an ar-15 she kept under her bed cole
said she shot him in the hallway of
their home in self-defense the jury must
have believed her attorneys as they
found her not guilty of both charges
after just four hours of deliberating
once the jury was done deciding
wednesday afternoon judge rappella read
the verdict
at this time the jury has reached
unanimous verdicts on both counts
i will read them individually
as for count one that is the charge of
murder
the jury has found the defendant not
guilty
they have made the finding that the
state of ohio did not prove beyond a
reasonable doubt all of the elements of
murder as charged in count one of the
indictment as for count two felonious
assault
the jury found the defendant not guilty
therefore it is a not guilty finding on
both counts
criminal defense attorney adam conte and
co-host terry austin are back to discuss
the self-defense acquittal of audrey
cole terry if you blinked you missed
this trial it was all done in what like
two and a half days why do you think the
jury found her not guilty so quickly
you know we don't get many not guilty
verdicts but i think the defense was
able to show that cole actually did fear
for her life she had had serious bodily
injury before he previously beat her up
while she was pregnant and so i think
that fact worked in her favor and the
husband was twice her size the defense
was
pointing out during its summation that
ohio has um stand your ground law and
you don't have to retreat and i think
that too was another reason that they
came to the conclusion so quickly adam
that's the conclusion let's talk about
how we got there are you surprised
because i know some people are
that the defense won a self-defense case
without putting on their client or a
single witness
in a vacuum yes i would be surprised the
facts of this case though i think they
they nailed it i mean the prosecution
had very little evidence the fact that
from jury selection to verdict is under
three days is unheard of for a
misdemeanor shoplifting case let alone a
murder case i mean there was an evidence
there and the evidence that was there
was really sort of in her favor so
although normally i would say yeah
self-defense you got to get up there you
got to really explain it you got to show
the jury why you were in fear
this just wasn't that case and and and
thankfully the jury got it right yeah i
think to the defense's credit uh while
she didn't take the stand as we just saw
there a moment ago her interrogation
video and her 9-1-1 call kind of put it
all out there so maybe she didn't need
to take the stand her story was already
there uh but of course it could also
just be the jury thought you shouldn't
be able to beat up your girlfriend like
that and just acquitted her of that but
we'll never know we'll see how it plays
out thank you both when we come back
inside the man of the accused waffle
house shooter written letters from the
travis reign king are read in court as
defense attorneys say he grappled with
delusion what famous celebrities he
called on for help
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily on
day four of the waffle house shooting
trial celebrity taylor swift takes
center stage as the defense alleges
suspect travis ranking had a delusional
relationship with a pop star
prosecutors say ranking walked into a
waffle house in nashville tennessee and
opened fire in 2018 four people were
killed and others were injured after a
massive 34-hour manhunt involving almost
every three-letter agency in the country
ranking was taken into custody the trial
was put on hold for months as ranking
was treated for schizophrenia a judge
later deemed him fit to stand trial
defense attorneys are arguing insanity
saying ranking had severe mental health
issues at the time of the shooting on
wednesday travis rankings or
hand-written letters were read on the
stand a detective told jurors he
addressed the letters to taylor swift
and oprah winfrey claiming what ranking
called a cruel relationship was swiff
taylor i'm really confused right now i
don't know if it was you in the pictures
on instagram or someone who looks like
you do you really have a twin sister
which one am i in love with then
i want the tailor that wrote those
beautiful songs and sang to me at her
concert
maybe taylor 1 wrote half and taylor 2
wrote half
oprah i'm writing you because i'm in
love with taylor swift and i don't know
if i'm delusional or not i started
writing taylor june 2nd 2015.
the letters were about dreams that i was
having i saw taylor for the first time
september 29th 2015.
it was at a concert and she mouthed the
words hello to me while she was singing
a song
after that i started to
after that i started to notice that what
i was saying to her was getting repeated
back to me on the internet
also things that i was doing on my phone
and computer
i wrote her and gave her permission to
do those things because she was being
nice to me and i didn't want her to feel
guilty
later i took back permission for her to
do that because she started being
cruel and lying about everything
she catfished me on the internet made me
fall in love with her and then started
being
nasty to
me adam starr witnesses and medical
examiners have testified how would you
rather measure the prosecution's case in
saying the insanity of defense doesn't
apply here
well it's tricky you know i was watching
the testimony earlier of this and of
their expert witness
and
i i think i think the prosecution has
done a good job in trying to poke holes
in it by showing uh areas where he was
really competent like him packing his
backpack with silver bars and it was
really sort of a plan sort of it seemed
premeditated and planned by a cognizant
mind uh but i mean listen you listen to
those letters and those letters are
obviously incredibly helpful for the
defense so it's just it's such a back
and forth right now it's so hard to put
on an insanity defense i think the
prosecution's going to get the
conviction but it's been a very
interesting trial
interesting to say the least terry let's
look at it from the other side is there
a chance for the defense to win an
insanity defense argument and what do
you think they need to prove to the jury
in order to get there
well under tennessee law what they'd
have to do is show that at the time of
the offense
he did not know what he was doing he had
a severe mental illness and it caused
him to not understand the consequences
of his actions honestly i do agree with
adam you know and they have to show that
through clear and convincing evidence i
don't think they're going to be able to
show this because there's so much
evidence that he did understand what was
going on he knew the difference between
right and wrong he tried to hide after
the fact he ran from the scene he took
his clothes off he had a change of
clothes so i think that at the end of
the day the prosecution is going to be
able to show that while he might have a
mental illness or defect he knew what he
was doing and he knew the consequences
of his actions so he would be found
guilty all right we'll see how that
plays out in closing arguments as they
tie it all together thank you both for
joining us always a pleasure and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you